(loud boom)
- It kind of ignited the fire.
- It just ignites.
- Hello, Believe Nation. It's Evan.
My one word is believe,
and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves,
and my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey today,
we're going to learn how to
ignite the fire within you.
And as always, if you hear something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it down the comments below
and put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired,
and if you're leaving a comment
within the first few hours
of this video going live,
you have a chance to win one of two
daily prizes that we have.
Good luck.
(majestic music)
- You will not outwork me.
It's not about being the
best motivational speaker
in the world.
It's about being the most consistent
motivational speaker in the world.
And so, when you watch me,
even if you don't like me,
and you're into motivation,
you've got to fool with me, why?
Because I'm on everything!
"ET, was that you on a Dick's
commercial?" Yep, it was.
How do you do this?
Day after day, dedicating
your life to the search
for a few more feet?
"ET, you doin stuff the
Olympics?" Absolutely.
"ET, was that you on the
..." Yep, that was me.
"ET, did you do that?" `Yep, you saw me.
"What you doin for Cleveland
on a jumbo screen?"
Yep, that was me
You will not outwork me.
High-school drop out.
Yes, your vocabulary
count is deeper than mine.
Yeah, absolutely, yep,
you look better than me.
Suit, asymmetric look, yep,
you got me beat all day.
You got me!
Grew up on the other side
of town, two parents,
great network, you got ...
I'm not gon' lie! You
way sweeter than I am!
You got all the stuff. You've got it all.
But you will not out work me.
Because your height has nothing
to do with my work ethic.
Your face has nothing to
do with my work ethic.
Your two-parent back
ground has nothing to do
with my work ethic.
You will not outwork me.
On your jet, you will not outwork me.
In your Bentley, you will not outwork me.
And there are those of you in this room,
the reason why this stuff
aint happening for you,
'cause you gettin' outworked!
Come on! Call the best
motivational speakers in the world.
Give us seven days, let us go
all over the world and speak.
Come on!
And while you in the green
room putting on your makeup,
you will not outwork me.
I'm bein real.
You will not outwork me.
While you doin' photo shoots,
you won't. I'm working.
You all bein' outworked in your marriage.
You're bein' outworked in your job.
You're bein' outworked with your kids.
Your kid's in a gang. Why?
'Cause somebody lovin' on 'em
more than you lovin' on 'em.
They in a gang.
They in a gang 'cause
you ain't hardly at home.
You're being outworked!
You got somebody else in
the hood who got more,
they got your kid here
more than you got 'em!
And you like, "I just can't
believe this society today!"
It's not the society, you got outworked!
Some dude up the block
is spending more time
with your son than you are!
Some guy on the block
is tellin' your daughter
how cute she is and you not,
cause you grindin' you workin',
but you thought when I told
you 120, I just meant at work.
I mean everywhere.
You will not outwork me!
You might make money, but
your marriage might not be.
I'm gon' get you on all fronts.
- When you think about life,
everybody wants the prize,
but nobody wants the process.
Everybody wants the championship,
but nobody wants the day to day.
Everybody wants the win game,
but nobody wants to put in
the work that it takes to win games.
In the Bible, it talks
about in Proverbs, it says,
"The laborers appetite works for him.
And his hunger drives him on."
And so, my question to
you all is, what's your
appetite for winning?
Because if you have a
appetite for winning,
your hunger will drive you every day.
Your hunger will take
you to the weight room.
Your hunger will take you past Durden two.
Your hunger will take
you past the opposition.
you past the adversity.
Your hunger will take you past
the trial and tribulation.
Your hunger will take you
to that fourth quarter,
when there's four zeros on that clock,
you have to empty that bucket,
you have given everything
you had in that game.
See, it's a certain mindset
man, when you attack this thing.
The game of football,
it's not about skill.
That's what people miss the boat on.
This game is not about, it
has nothing to do with skill.
It has nothing to do
with the 40 yard dash.
It has nothing to do with
jumping a 40 inch vertical.
What this game is about, it's about will!
That's it!
It's not about skill,
this game is about will!
And so the moment that
you make up in your mind,
the day that you make up in your mind
that you are going to
play this game for God
and give everything you got to it,
you can't help but to
give everything you got.
And that's the moment
that you will realize,
this game has nothing to do with skill.
I've seen plenty of talented guys fold.
I've seen plenty of talented
guys get hit in the mouth,
and they didn't want it.
I've seen plenty of talented
guys get punched in the face,
and they go back to the
sideline and they stand beside
they coach, and they
don't want it no more.
They make up excuses.
I've seen plenty of talented
guys that ran a 4.2 in a 40
and they bench press 325
pounds and when 31 came up,
they tapped they helmet,
to come out of the game.
That has nothing to do with skill.
- So I went to the next
more than necessary
to start talking to people
and seeking and asking
for what I wanted.
And leveraging relationships
and trying to find out,
how did people do it
that went ahead of me?
How did they do it? And then,
what is it I need to do?
How is it I need to train
myself, to develop myself?
What's the resources that will be required
in order to make it happen?
And as I start seeking
out and asking questions,
I started running into people that said,
"I know someone who can help you do that."
And they helped me get
connected with those people.
Remember, we have so much
energy that can take us so far.
It's necessary that you
hook up with some other
inner energy that can take
you to the next level.
I hooked up with 'em, they said,
"Les, let's go!" I said, "Away we go!"
(applause)
And guess what? Here we are!
(laughing)
I love it!
You want your stuff?
It's necessary you take
responsibility for it.
That you make it happen,
that you don't give up,
that you don't take any
objection or dissapointment
or defeats personally, that
you keep on keepin' on,
that you don't decide
that, "I can't make it"
because you can't see the
light at the end of the tunnel!
That you realize that's
a part of the program.
And here's something
you've got to resolve.
Say this to yourself everyday.
See, as long as you breathin',
you got a shot at your dream.
That's the way I resolve.
Say this please, it's not over ...
- [Audience] It's not over ...
- Until I win.
- [Audience] Until I win.
- You've got that right.
(applause)
It's not over until I win.
Not over till I get through it.
It's not over till I get over.
Not over till I get what I want.
Door can't open today? Look out.
I'm going to come back
and take the hinges off!
(laughter)
That's how you got to do that.
You've got to have that kind of courage,
that type of determination.
If you want to make it happen, it's you.
That you've got to take
personal responsibility
to make it happen.
- My name is Michael Jordan.
And I play professional
basketball for the Chicago Bulls.
(intense music)
- [Announcer] 32 seconds to go.
A one point lead for Georgetown.
Gordy, the block.
The time: 18, shot!
Jordan! Michael Jordan!
- IF I had to trace my abolition,
the Michael Jordan abolition,
it'd always have to start back in college.
Getting a shot against Georgetown in 1982,
when I really didn't know
exactly what I was doin'.
- [Announcer] North Carolina has won
the 1982 NCAA championship.
- It awakened a person inside of me
to excel.
To compete to excel, to be one
of the best, or be the best.
That drove me. And I
guess, with that shot,
it kind of ignited the
fire inside of me that
nothing was going to stop me.
- [Announcer] Jordan down
the middle, all the way!
Jordan to the hoop! Ho!
Sends it out to Jordan,
down the lane, all the way!
Jordan, who has it on the
break, trying to go all the way
in! Oh!
(loud applause)
- [Interviewer] And it
was, you regularly say
that failure propels you.
Are there any instances
in your past, truly,
where you couldn't get over, and why?
- Nope.
And by the way, by the way,
that's the same answer for
everybody in this room.
That's what humans are good at.
We all fail.
We've all failed.
My parents haven't been
killed, my child, I mean,
there's people that
have their children die.
Like, could you imagine?
Like, the shit I deal?
Like, listen, unfortunately,
or fortunately,
depends on how one wants to look at it,
I'm a pretty optimistic guy.
I lost three of my four
grandparents before I was really ...
Before I knew them: two before I was born
and one very early on.
So, you know, it's easy
for me to be happy.
I have my shit in the right order:
the health and wellbeing of my family.
And there's nothing even
remotely close to that.
Not even remotely.
People have gotten through much worse.
This is why I'm trying to
recall our grandparents
and our great grandparents,
people who were persecuted and killed ...
We do not have real headaches.
You know, I don't know why
I have this highly emotional
and then completely
unemotional part of me, but
I mix them together to create the balance,
and that's what works for me.
So, of course there's nothing
that I couldn't get up from.
Like every other human
ever, besides somebody
who now lives in some weird
cave that we don't know about.
You know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] I do.
- We are strong as shit.
We're really fucking strong.
We're just being sold that we're not.
'Cause there's a lot of
money, a lot of money
in telling us that
we're not pretty enough,
thin enough, smart enough, good enough.
Fuck that.
I want to tell you, you're
the fucking best, go do shit.
- The passion I've always had for business
and being an entrepreneur
that transfers into the maths,
I've always been passionate.
Some people thought, you know,
it's more OCD than anything
else, which I think is a great
trait for an entrepreneur.
I mentioned the stamp
business, I would stay up
till three, four in the morning,
even though I had to
get up and go to school.
And read Linn's Stamp News
and Scott's Stamp Journals
and have them all memorized and use
that to give myself an edge.
Even when I was in college,
I'd be in the library reading
business books and just looking
for business biographies
and just reading all I
could about business.
When I had MicroSolutions and, you know,
I started with no money.
I would pull all nighters in
front of borrowed computers,
teaching myself software
and how to program.
- Life demands that you pick up the pace.
If you don't pick up the pace,
you're gon' be left behind.
I'm amazed at the people that
lack the flexibility to pick up the pace.
They just get in a rut.
"I'll stroll down here,
and I'm gon' stroll back."
"I'm gon' stroll over here,
I'm gon' stroll over there."
One of the most amazing
things about the disaster
at Malaysia is that, when it happened,
everybody had to pick up the pace.
All the news media had
to pick up the pace.
They were bookin' night
flights and flying over here
and flying over there,
somebody had to work over time.
"Wont' be home for three days."
Typin' in the middle of the
night, research goin' on.
Because when somethin' happens,
everybody got to pick up the pace!
That's why I can't deal with people
who cannot pick up the pace.
Don't be strollin', when
I got to a 9-1-1 on you.
I need people who can pick up the pace!
(applause)
Front your neighbor and
say, "Pick up the pace!"
- [Audience] Pick up the pace!
- Something's about to happen.
Pick up the pace,
something's about to happen.
Pick up the pace, something
is about to happen.
Pick up the pace,
something's about to happen.
I came to tell the young
people, pick up the pace,
pick up the pace, pick up the pace,
something is about to happen!
The danger of low expectations.
- [Audience] Boo!
- I would rather aim for
the stars and not hit them
than to not aim at all.
I would rather go after it and not get it
than not go after it at all.
I'd rather try and fail
than not try at all.
I don't want to live with the
idea, wonder what would have
happened, had I done more with my life.
I'm going to go for it,
come hell or high water.
I'm goin' after my destiny!
Touch your neighbor and say, "run!"
- [Audience] Run!
- You got to run after your destiny.
You can't stroll after your destiny.
You can't walk after your destiny.
You got to run! Somebody holla run!
- [Audience] Run!
(applause)
- You got to run.
You got to run.
You can't just wake up in the mornin',
"Let me see what's gon' happen today.
I don't know what I'm gon' do.
I don't know what I'm gon' wear.
I don't know what I'm gon' cook.
I don't know where I'm gon' go.
I just woke up."
Oh, you should stay in the bed.
Give today to somebody who's
gon' run after their destiny.
Give today to somebody who has
a plan, who has a strategy.
Because success is never an accident.
And if you don't want
it, get out of my way.
Because there are some people
who want to do something
with their life, who will run.
- When I was in the seventh grade,
my buddy moved away to Oregon.
There was a week where I went
up to visit him in Portland.
I flew up there by
myself, go to his house,
and the whole thing was
is, "Hey, he's going to be
in school on some of these days this week,
so you can shadow him to school,
or you can hang out until
he gets out of school."
I shadow him one day and I was
like, "This is fuckin' weird,
I'm going to stay at your house and wait."
But in his room, there were four things
that were very important.
A Stiff Little Finger's
record, there was a All record,
the Dinosaur Jr. record, and
there was an electric guitar.
So, what I did was, I would
play those three albums
on vinyl, and I would go
over and pick up this guitar
to keep myself entertained
throughout the day
for those three or four days
that he would be at school.
Until he would come back
and we would skate at night
and do whatever.
That changed my life.
You know, changed my life.
The hearing punk rock music
and picking up the guitar,
something clicked where it's almost like,
there's a bunch of gasoline on the ground
and someone flicks a
cigarette and it just ignites.
You know, it's just ...
It was a chemical reaction
that just flipped on a switch
that nothing could take
that guitar out of my hand
from that point forward.
- I think that personal
ambition is worth fighting for.
It really is something that,
if you don't fight for,
you're going to regret it
for the rest of your life.
And if you regret it, you're
going to be an unhappy person.
If you're an unhappy person,
it's going to affect your family.
So you can see the chain
of command all the way down
that it can be pretty devastating.
The common asset is we
fight for our family.
Uh, yeah, but fighting for
family starts with you.
So, you got to fight for peace of mind.
That's what I think you have to go for.
You know, what makes you
happy enough in your life
that you want to make other people happy.
- High performance is anything but easy.
And staying on top's even
harder than getting to the top.
Now, I've been on the
top of my game, arguably,
for three and a half decades.
I haven't had to work in 35 years.
People ask me how do I
get up in the morning?
I get up fired up.
I'm fired up, I've been
high on life since 1974.
That I thought about it and, actually,
since I got OCS fifty years ago, today.
Where failure's not an option.
And I do fail, but when
I do fail, I am so ...
I can't believe it!
It must be an error; there must be a typo.
Because I'm so used to winning.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed the video.
I'd love to know, what did you think?
What was the single biggest
takeaway that you took
from this video that you're
going to apply to your life
or to your business somehow?
Leave it down in the comments below.
If you're within the first
couple hours of this video
going live, you have a chance to win one
of two daily prizes, as well.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Kris Schantz.
Kris thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word and posting that
awesome picture to Twitter.
I really appreciate the support, man.
And I hope you enjoyed the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(loud boom)